Approximately 1.26 billion cells in your body
will die and be replaced with new cells, in
the time it takes to watch this video.
Your body also makes a brand new skeleton
every three months and a completely new layer
of skin every month.
Your body is remarkable.
Here’s some of the most amazing things your
body does.
1.
There’s 7.2 billion people in the world
yet no two are the same, even identical twins
are surprisingly dissimilar.
It’s common knowledge that we all have a
unique fingerprint but did you know that every
human has a unique tongue print too.
2.
Scientists estimate there are 37.2 trillion
cells in the average human body.
But the numbers are still mind blowing if
we go a bit larger than just cells.
Every square inch of your skin contains 6
metres of blood vessels, 3.6 metres of nerve
fibres, 1,300 nerve cells and 100 sweat glands.
Also if unravelled, your circulatory system,
that’s your arteries, veins and capillaries,
would stretch around the earth four times.
3.
The adult human body consists of 206 bones,
and more than half of those are in the hands
and feet.
4.
The largest artery runs down the centre of
your body, it’s called your aorta and it
diameter is almost as large as a garden hose.
By contrast, the smallest blood vessels in
your body, capillaries, are so small that
it would take 10 of them side by side to equal
the thickness of a single strand of human
hair.
5.
The human body has some rather disgusting
habits too.
Your body will lose 100 strands of hair per
day and over 10 billion flakes of skin.
And your body produces 1.5 litres of mucus
every day.
Also over the course of your lifetime, your
body will produce two swimming pools worth
of saliva.
6.
Your body has the potential to become superhuman.
In cases of extreme danger adrenaline rushes
through your body, which leads to an increased
level of oxygen flow to your muscles, giving
your super human strength, seemingly from
nowhere.
There have been several cases of people single
handily, lifting cars and other heavy objects
to free loved ones.
7.
Your body can also predict the weather.
When a storm is on its way the pressure in
the atmosphere drops, which in turn makes
the pressure on your joint fluids rise.
So if your joints are aching, it’s your
bodies way of telling you there’s a storm
coming.
8.
Nerve impulses that travel to and from your
brain travel as fast as 170 miles miles per
hour.
9.
Your brain can remember 50,000 different scents.
And smelling something you’ve smelt before
can actually trigger you to recall memories.
10.
Your body is surprisingly resourceful, you
could remove your stomach, spleen, one kidney,
80% of your intestines and 70% of your liver
and still be able to survive.
11.
The skin is the body’s largest organ but
it also acts as a huge shield wall against
bacteria.
The skin constantly secretes antibacterial
substances.
Most bacteria that lands on the skin dies
instantly.
12.
Whenever we learn something new or create
a new memory our brain add a new connection
between it’s neurons, these connections
are called synapses.
During the fist month of a human’s life
the number of synapses in your brain increases
dramatically, from 50 trillion, to 1 quadrillion.
13.
Arguably one of the most important structural
parts of your body is your big toe.
This seemingly insignificant appendage is
a crucial component in maintaining our balance
and propelling us forward whilst walking and
running.
14.
The human eye can distinguish up to a million
different colours and take in more information
in a single gaze than the largest telescope
known to man.
Which by the way is on a mountain top in northern
Chile and it’s creatively named the European
Extremely Large Telescope.
15.
But surprisingly your body is a lot less human
than you may think.
In fact your body is actually more bacteria
than human.
For every cell in your body there are at least
10 bacteria.
That’s hundreds of trillions of bacteria,
they live in every nook and cranny of your
body.
But don’t worry, less than 1 percent of
the bacteria in your body can cause disease
or illness.
The majority are beneficial to your health.